they begin in the Gaza Strip where 40
Israeli military planes carried out a
series of airstrikes overnight at least
13 people have been killed three of them
are leaders in alcud's brigades as the
military wing of the Islamic Jihad group
the Palestinian Health Ministry says
women and children are also amongst the
Dead
well earlier outside filed this report
from Gaza City
three commanders in Alcott brigades the
military wing of Islamic Jihad have been
assassinated by Israeli drones
the Israeli military also announced that
40 were jets and drones carried out the
operation and assassinating these
leaders and the airstrikes following
them also civilians around the
apartments that were targeted now the
targeting happened to two residential
apartments in residential buildings one
of them is right there as uh if the
camera can pan over it's right there in
the middle of Gaza City while the other
apartment was in Rafa the southern part
of the Gaza Strip a lot of Destruction
has been caused to that residential
building and of course a lot of injuries
happened from that targeting now the
Israeli Army has called this military
operation that it has carried against
the Gaza Strip as the protective arrow
and it announced the assassination or
the success of the assassination of the
Islamic Jihad Targets in an official
statement by alcott's brigades the
military wing of Islamic Jihad they
mourned their Martyrs the great
mujahideen leaders Jihad al-ranim Khalil
albertani and Tara kaiserdin and also
mourned their families their wives and
children who were killed in the
assassination attacks
let's go now to West Jerusalem where we
can speak to Muhammad Jam June and
Mohammed what are we hearing from the
Israeli side in the wake of all these
strikes
so Laura we know that at this hour there
is a situational assessment that is
going on uh prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is there along with other
security officials to discuss what
transpired earlier in the day and also
talk about next steps we also know that
there is a scheduled cabinet meeting and
a meeting of security officials uh later
this evening as well and we expect that
once that happens we'll be hearing more
about what plans the Israeli officials
might be taking in these next couple of
days and going forward what's
interesting is we've also heard from the
foreign minister Israeli foreign
minister Ellie Cohen has cut short a
trip to India he announced on Twitter
that he's coming back in light of
security concerns and the situation on
the ground here so he will be here later
today to uh to join that cabinet meeting
and also there was a tweet earlier in
the day from Israel's defense minister
yowav Gallant in which he said that the
Israeli military had carried out its
Mission Against the leadership of the
Islamic Jihad in the Gaza Strip he went
on to say any terrorist who harms the
citizens of Israel will regret it what's
interesting about that tweet is it's the
first we've heard from any Israeli
official
in which it comes close to any kind of
confirmation that Israel indeed targeted
leadership of Islamic Jihad all the
other statements we've seen thus far
from Israel's military is that they
targeted uh weapons manufacturing sites
military encampments in the Gaza Strip
This is really the first indication that
we will be hearing more from Israeli
officials that this was a targeted
assassination against leadership of
Islamic Jihad of The Klutz Brigade and
Islamic Jihad in the Gaza Strip but
we're waiting to hear more and we expect
we'll get more details in the hours to
come Laura and authorities also watching
and waiting to see if Rockets more
Rockets are fired from Gaza into Israel
citizens near the border have been
warned to stay near shelters
[Music]
that's right uh what we've heard from
Israeli officials is they are asking
residents in those areas in the South
areas the Border Gaza to take shelter to
stay close to home they've also closed
schools because Israel is expecting that
this will escalate the situation they
are anticipating that most likely there
will be rocket fire from the Gaza Strip
fire toward Israel especially toward the
South uh in the hours to come and we've
also heard from Israeli officials
they've said to various media Outlets
here that um basically what happens next
is going to be dependent upon Islamic
Jihad and Hamas and it all will depend
on the level of escalation that they
choose going forward how many Rockets
are fired which targets inside Israel
are targeted which targets are hit so
right now there is a lot of concern
certainly this is something that wasn't
expected today but clearly you can see
that a lot of planning went into it and
that Israel had given a lot of thought
as far as the airstrikes that they
conducted inside Gaza in the overnight
hours a lot of of concern at this hour
about what exactly is going to happen it
had been assumed that Israel really
didn't want to escalate things at this
time this looks like an escalatory move
but at the same time people here are
hoping that things won't get too far out
of hand Laura indeed okay I haven't done
for the moment thanks very much let's go
now to occupied West Bank there we can
speak to Anita Ibrahim she joins us from
Ramallah neither what reaction have we
had from the Palestinian leaders there
we've heard from the Palestinian
president's office the Palestinian prime
minister as well as the Palestinian
Ministry of Foreign Affairs they're all
basically saying the same thing they're
condemning what they call an aggression
on Gaza what they describe as a heinous
crime and they are all calling on the
International Community to intervene to
stop the Israeli acts there they're
saying that Israel is acting in a way
that is against international law and it
has a free hand they are requiring the
International Community to do its job
but let's not forget that the
Palestinian Authority when it comes to
Gaza it doesn't have much leverage in
the previous rounds of escalation we've
seen that Egypt alongside with the
fighting groups in Gaza and Israel has
been really the mediator that led to
calm or LED to ceasefires and so on so
the Palestinian authorities for its
people are concerned here as just issue
in condemnations asking for help from
the International Community but really
how is it going to affect people's
reality on the ground not much even if
you talk about the West Bank itself
there has been almost daily raids in the
occupied West Bank some of the very uh
tragic when it comes to the results of
casualties this morning in Annapolis we
had an Israeli raid that ended up taking
two Palestinians
to hostage these two Palestinians
according to the Israeli forces have
been accused of committing shooting
attacks against Israelis as a result 12
Palestinians were wounded with live
ammunition and in addition you have 130
people who suffered tear gas inhalation
so even in the West Bank itself the
Palestinian Authority has limited
leverage when it comes to stopping the
Israeli actions on the ground we've
heard of understandings before to come
the tension but so far if you look at
that ground if you look at what's been
happening this really it's going
continue the Israeli settlement plans
continue and Palestinians say they're
being left alone fighting a military
occupation that has been on their land
for decades okay neither Abraham
bringing us the latest that from
Ramallah thanks very much Nida